consumer spending habits are totally
different today than they were before
covid
people are using credit cards less and
paying off their credit card debts
a lot of people don't like the idea of
revolving credit card debt
and they know that they pay a lot and
interest on
the revolving debt but a lot of times
they
that's something that they can't people
aren't spending as much because you
can't go out of their house as much
people are taking advantage of that
opportunity to kind of take some debt
off their own
personal balance sheet while millennials
are shunning consumer debt and spending
more online
companies that offer buy now pay later
options are growing in popularity
if you've ever tried to purchase
something online during checkout there
may be an option to pay in installments
so you don't have to pay for everything
upfront
that's what a firm does when you want to
buy something new
and don't want to add it to your
revolving credit card debt
essentially through a firm you can see
what you're going to pay in interest
up front so it might say all right for
this new
um watch you're going to pay 200
and you're going to pay it off in six
weeks and you're going to pay
you know whatever amount of money each
every two weeks
to pay it off that is different from
when you have revolving credit card debt
there is um compounding interest if you
have the same 200 expense and you only
pay 20
a month or fifty dollars a month you are
still
paying interest on the balance the rest
of it that you haven't paid off so the
interest compounds and you end up paying
more in interest
a firm is valued at about 26 billion
dollars and they expect to make over 760
million dollars in revenue in 2021.
they make money from consumers in the
form of interest rates
max levchin is the co-founder and ceo of
a firm
and the people i talked to would
describe it as is really all business
he's a
he's very competitive he's a a serious
guy
so i think roughly half of the time
it's charging interest to consumers and
that ranges from zero to 30 percent
on average from one set of loans that it
has issued i think the average interest
rate was about 24
and they make money from merchant fees
too so
merchants pay every time a customer
buys one of their products and uses a
firm and the reason they pay
the you know the argument a firm makes
is that
people buy more when you have a firm
when you can use a firm
these retailers see higher order sizes
they see more orders when they enable
something like a firm
and they decide okay it's worth it to
pay this you know
four five six percent fee um so that
i get more volume and get more sales
according to consulting firm oliver
wyman
americans spent over 20 billion dollars
using buy now pay later programs in
2020.
two of the uh the probably most notable
competitors
are after pay which is based in
australia but has a big u.s
presence and karna which
is based in sweden but also has a big
u.s presence
and so they their fees
are a little lower on average i believe
after pay is 45 karna i believe three or
four percent and a firm roughly
six percent i asked them this recently
why
why would people pay higher fees and
what a firm will say is that
you know we're delivering a better
experience it's easy to use a firm
uh we don't have late fees some
merchants like that
after paying karna do have weight if you
don't pay out time there are late fees
and so i think those are some of the
reasons
that a merchant will will choose a firm
over karna or afterpay but a firm isn't
a bank you know they don't have a base
of deposits they can
they can go off of so they need to fund
their loans by basically
packaging them into a security and
securities get sold to other investors
they're good at this capital markets
aspect of
funding the funding they want getting
funding for the loans and
selling them and at a reasonable cost to
a firm because the firm has to pay to do
this
it's not that easy to fund these really
big two thousand dollar
loans and so that is another i think
competitive advantage that they
they say they have is is being able to
fund these bigger loans
people process 2.1 billion dollars in
transactions through a firm in the last
quarter of 2020.
like a firm these programs are popular
with consumers because they see what
they're paying for up front
instead of being hit with credit card
interest rates later
it helps with budgeting there's kind of
an end date you you need to pay this off
in two months you know and so it gives
you i think it gives more financial
discipline
it it you can't just kind of keep
kicking the can down the road and say
all right i want you to
put 20 towards this this month or 30 pay
the minimum of my credit card
it i think it really causes you to have
more financial discipline and i think
people like that too
i think that they're gonna expand into
different financial services but i don't
think it'll be like 2020 where
it grew like crazy i mean i think it was
a unique year
i think that you have um
you had the stimulus you had a lot of
economic uncertainty where people were
afraid to use their credit cards
i think you know you're going to see
people eventually moving back to credit
cards a little bit more
um that would be that would be my guess
as those glass financial uncertainty
and so i don't think it will grow as
much as it did in 2020 but i think
they'll keep growing
you